welcome back to pj chain design today we
would like to take a look
on how to do the 3d model in rhino for
this cross
pendant are you ready let's get started
we are going to start it at the top view
and we are going to draw the cross
outline first
the first one i'm going to do
about 22 millimeter and for
about four millimeter high and the
straight one i'm going to do
about four millimeter wide and
31 millimeter tall for example like this
and you can do whatever proportion that
you like
um i'm just rendering to come up this
number
then i'm going to use a line tool to
align to the center
and kind of moving this up to whatever
that's the right proportion
all right so now that i have this i'm
going to make them into
three dimension i'm going to draw a
straight line from the midpoint
up and roughly about 1.5 millimeter
and that will be our reference line
we're going to snap in here here and
here
so you see that little bit triangle over
here after
i do that i want to also want to making
a copy
uh simply just copy this one to here
so then we will have the same profile
and i need to rotate this one back to
this point
all right so now we have
on our perspective which is something
like this
i'm going to use the surface command and
we
are going to extrude this curve straight
both sides equal no and going from this
point to this point
so then we get that we're going to do
the same thing
on this side so we kind of get
things like this after that i simply
gonna pick up
everybody and we are going to use the
trim tool
and we want to trim somewhere in the
middle a lot of time it may be hard for
you to see
which one is which is because it's
harder to
know where is the contour line and
sometimes what you can do
is you can explode them and join it back
so now you can see the line
in the middle so it's easier for you to
trim so we're gonna pick up both of them
and we're gonna hit the trim command
and we will like to trim the line here
and also the line here and we're gonna
trim
over here and flip it over trim it over
here so now we have it perfectly meet
there
don't forget to join them back together
i would like to cut out a 45 degree
surface
right at the end so i'm going to use the
rectangle and we're going to creating a
surface first so something a little bit
taller like this
and simply just have this one to
rotate it 45 degrees so let's go from
here to here and type it minus 45
in this direction okay so then we
have that we can simply just mirror to
the other side
then we have both of them and then this
two end um
simply what we're gonna do is pick up
all the surface
and we want to trim the one we don't
need it so we don't need this one and
this one
also this tiny triangle here and here
and don't forget to join them we are
going to do the same on the other side
let's go ahead to use the rectangle with
the three point
one two and the third one is going up
and we simply also going to have this
one
to rotate 45 degree here and again we
wanted to mirror to the other side so
once we have that again we're gonna pick
up all three of them
and let's go ahead to trim the extra
there there
and join them let me temporarily to hide
this one and that's
dealing with this curve here we are
going to trim each other
again get rid of the one in the middle
and make sure you join them together and
turning back what we were hiding so now
with this
curve we can extrude it straight down
and make sure solid equal no because we
need to
connect it to the top piece and i want
to extrude it down maybe just a little
bit over one millimeter let's go ahead
to join them and use the command
cap so now it is solid that's double
make sure
it is closed solid poly surface on our
property
okay to make them not as sharp looking
as you can see the render this is like
way too sharp i want to give it a
chamfer
edges and let's transfer the edges for
something really small like
0.2 millimeter and see how does it go
all right so when you have a chamfer and
when all the point coming into
that point we usually will have this
opening right there
and this is kind of pretty easy fix here
so what we can do
is we can use the surface from planar
curve
and we can simply pick up all this curve
then that will be a surface there
again we are going to use a surface from
planet curve i'm going to pick up that
all right and if surface from planar
curve it doesn't work mean
it is actually not flat so another uh
command we can use
is surface from two three four uh edges
then we will get that surface and we're
gonna do that for
all the corner which has an
opening there
all right so once you do that make sure
that they are
it is a closed solid polished surface
and let's take a look on the ghost view
and this will be the cross all right so
now we need to
define a space that we are going to do
the b setting i simply wanted to do
is to duplicate the edges
of this one this one
this one and this one
and once you do that make sure you join
them together then we wanted to
offset a wall thickness there now
because it's not flat we will not only
want to use the offset we want to
offset the curve on the surface and it
will ask you like
what is the distance i'm going to set it
up here for 0.6 millimeter
and we are going to do a test here
i am going to shoot simply using the
solid command and you have extruded
planar curves straight
and i want to to cut it down i want to
make sure both are equal yes
and i want them to go in down about 0.8
millimeter
so then i'm going to giving
a test by doing a bowling difference
this one out of this
and then you will have that opening
there okay so i'm going to go back one
step
since this is symmetrical so i'm going
to mirror to the other side
and having that to mirror to
the top all right
and we are going to do the bowling on
this one first so that let's go ahead to
do the bowling difference and this one
out of those full color here all right
so then we have that opening
the next one it's going to be
the same way let's duplicate the edges
of
this guy this guy this one
and also the one at the end
let me do this side as well since we are
going to use the same command
and make sure you join them all right
and then we're going to pick up this
curve
let's do the same we want to offset on
the surface and this is the base surface
make sure you flip it inside and we
wanted to do 0.6 as well
the same thing over here
and then we can pick up this one and
this one let's go ahead to
extrude it curve straight and we wanted
the same point eight millimeter
on both sides then we can pick up this
extrusion
and this extrusion and we can mirror to
the other side
so now all we need to do is pulling
difference
this one out of this guy this guy
and two on the top all right so we have
that opening there
all right so uh for the stone setting i
actually want them to be
chamfered a little bit it will look much
nicer it's more like a bright cut there
so i'm gonna using the chamfer and we're
gonna do a test
first let's try this one and see how
that look
4.4 millimeter there
all right so that looks nice and if that
looks nice we're going to apply
to all the surfaces all the edges there
all right let's take a look on the
render view and see how they go
okay so this is a pretty good so far
and double check this is still a poly
uh closed solid poly surface all right
so now everything will find that's
uh dealing with the stone if you like to
know how to build a stone i have i will
put a link on the
right top corner here for you or if you
want to uh practice i want to download
this one
you can download the storm file with the
link at the description
below that will ask you to sign up my
newsletter and it will give you a link
to download this
uh file now we have a strong here and i
want to size the stone into the size
that i want
and i basically want to have about 1.2
millimeters so i'm going to
uh scale 3d and make sure um
my vertex it is
check on my
all snap so i'm going to stamping to
here to here
and just type it 1.2
and then that will be my stone let's
take a look on here and see
if the size is going to fit all right so
it looked like it was fitting into the
space really well
now i'm going to move my stone out and
do my stone setting on the side first
i'm going to draw a straight line this
is the line i'm going to pipe
and then we are going to using the pipe
command
to give a diameter about this compared
to the stone
and depends on how you like your stone
to be
set either is the shear prong or
is the individual prong and if you do
want to have a shared prong you might
need to get them a little bit bigger
okay you don't need to have it like the
two tall it just
as soon as they are a little bit taller
than the table then you should be fine
so i'm going to move it
up something like this and make this one
shorter
and this is will be my sheer prong i'm
going to moving just a little bit
like this all right and that's giving a
test
uh let's mirror this one to the other
side
and also mirror our stone to the other
side and see how that look
the stones shouldn't touch each other
and you want to have a gap
about 0.1 millimeter to 0.2 millimeters
so
this one is a little bit way too close
so i might need to move this stone out
a little bit like this and then at the
same time these two need to be moving
a little bit like this and if you need
to adjust
in you might just want to adjust one of
them
moving in a little bit or maybe a little
bit bigger and then we can mirror again
try to use the mirror instead of just
moving around
so i'm going to using this as a set we
are going to use
the linear array and we want to array go
from here to
maybe 20 of them and to somewhere about
here to be equal size all right so this
will be
our reference i'm going to delete the
first one and very last one
i'm going to making a copy just in case
i mess up
you know that first one and then uh i
don't need to have a lot of them for
that short horizontal arrangement
let's group this one first and simply
just move it back here
and we want to tilt it in the angle that
follow
with the triangle that we have on that
surface
and then we can moving and then we can
move it into the right place
somewhere over here it looks like we
have a more than
what we need so i'm going to ungroup
this one
and let's go ahead to delete some extra
here
sometimes people will fill in the space
with another
uh prong if that worked for you you can
go ahead to do that
since we got one and this is symmetrical
it's quite
easy we simply just going to mirror to
the other side
and again mirror one more time
to the top alright so then we'll have
that fill
now let's go ahead to work on the other
side is i'm gonna moving this and move
it about
at this place and now i'm looking at my
front view i want to tilt it again
really close to
the angle that i have and again i have
more than what i need so i'm just going
to
ungroup it and delete the extra
and we want to mirror to the other side
again click on both of them and
mirror to the top now the one on the top
we just need to ungroup bunch of them
and we wanted to delete
a bunch of them as well this stone
it's kind of inside of that shape and
we can kind of we're moving up a little
bit if you feel like it's too
jam close to the center all right after
that just put
the bail on it then you will have this
cross pendant with the b
setting i hope you enjoy the video the a
lot more trick and tip that i have on my
membership program so if you're
interesting please check out the
membership program for llamo
jewelry cat tutorial video thank you for
watching
i'll see you next
[Music]
you